so in this video i play one of my most
memorable title tuesdays ever i play
countless grand masters including a
former world women's champion
and also some guy named nepo so i had a
lot of instructive and fun games i
really think you'll enjoy them and as
usual all the games will be timestamped
in the video description so feel free to
hop around at your leisure
now before we get to the chest i do want
to give a big thank you to today's video
sponsor which is babel now if you
haven't heard of babel they are a
language learning app that makes
learning new languages fun and simple
and just like chess learning a new
language can help you connect with
people from all over the world there's
over a dozen different languages you can
learn using babel and it teaches you
real world practical conversations help
you in business travel and even
relationships
now recently i've been using babel to
learn bahasa indonesian
i went to indonesia back in 2017 and
2018
and it was a really fun trip i had a lot
of interesting people
but i really wish i had babel back then
to learn the language and more easily
interact with the people who i met and
with babel the lessons are very
digestible every lesson takes no more
than 10 minutes to complete
and it's super easy to do every day to
learn something new
and just enhance your understanding of a
new language so if you're interested in
trying out babel and learning a new
language
then i do have a special offer for my
viewers if you click the link in the
video description you can get 65 off
your subscription to babel and i really
hope it makes a positive impact in your
life so thanks again to babel for
sponsoring this video and now let's get
to some chess so addressing all the subs
and donors might have to wait until
after this game and i'm probably just
gonna stop liking a chat because now i'm
playing nepo
i'm playing nepo
playing the world championship
challenger
let's play london
oh i'm playing napo
ah he's playing this line
okay so i usually like to put the bishop
on c4
i think i'll play h
i forgot my prep let's play knight t2
first and then
bishop c4
it allows d5 but then bishop e2
it's not the most like
impressive opening prop but
it's something
can i take
rook b1
[Music]
i should really know what i'm doing here
but i don't
it's slightly unfortunate i think i'll
just castle
queen b6 i think i'll take
yeah that's a move
oh this is my game oh no it's not
you see three takes takes
ah there should be five
maybe there should be five's a way to go
hey it's gm bonnie thanks for the raid
if you're just joining i'm playing yon
nipponyachi
some chess player from russia
okay
uh c3 is a move i think c3 is reasonable
i mean he can really get my
uh both my bishops we could have a
situation where it's two knights versus
two bishops
but at least i'm achieving some like
solid formation
not too far down on time
that's a good move e5 might be coming
takes takes e5 c4 in the end
there's actually queen b3 in that line
[Music]
so the point is if e4 i take it because
there's a pin if that move
yeah it's not the prettiest of positions
this is just bishop e2
maybe rook d1
these pawns can be strong but they can
also be potential targets
objectively i'm probably a little bit
worse
put the rook and i don't want to leave
my thing undefended though
bishop here
discouraging a4
maybe i'll play for myself
okay do i want to play f3
maybe it's not too bad
queen b6 check king here
okay now queen a4
down a minute
i forgot nepo likes to move quickly
he also likes to think not at the
chessboard
at least during the world championship
match
okay i'm just trying to hold my own
oh no
i have to play c4 only move
it doesn't look good
but takes takes maybe it's playable
while b3
maybe queen c2
keep holding
[Music]
holding or hodling
thank you psychedelic gazelle
okay idea a4 and then
c5
i have to over defend the bishop so i
can mobilize my c pawn
and the thing for black once i get rid
of this pawn i can establish a
never mind
uh if i take
what's the point we trade
my knight will land on f1
oh i'm losing b2 in the end
but i might be mating in the end
oh okay so i have this move
well both my pawns are hanging though so
b3
okay there's one second increment
if v5 i have bishop d3 thankfully
defending
still trying to survive
wait i'm up a pawn
i didn't realize he sacked a pawn
i'm still under a lot of pressure though
what happens if i just take this
no that's
a thing
a4
h no not h3
a4 pro no
under a ton of pressure
knight
i g3 i should make loofed first
that's really weakening though
yeah there's this idea now at least the
night guards h2
i should look like queenie two
queenie two might come next come very
soon
now i want to get the queens of the
right now i have this move
i just want to trade and
not lose
trade
that's such a tricky move
i think it's okay though
just have to set up a blockade on c2 i
couldn't take a c2
ambition d5 coming
okay thankfully queens are off the board
i do a king d3
now bishop d5 intakes is the plan
a little bit nervous here
knight here is a
i'm also preventing bishop c6 which is
nice
yeah
uh-oh
i'm still okay i think
to say calm
oh i'm still on me chess i forgot to
change my title
sorry about that
don't hurt me
stop trying to hurt me
check
i'm laying for a win
might be taking some risk though
and hear this
no
what's happening here
am i still winning i might still be
winning
no
what happened to my thing
i've removed the wrong move oh i'm so
sad now
oh
i'm sure it was was it winning
he tricked me once and then he tricked
me twice
what's the same shame on me
i couldn't play this because bishop a7
yeah he probably said oh no my pawn
[Music]
and then just won my knights
yeah it's hard to advance
yeah a7 was a bad pre-move i was
expecting him to play h2
um
yeah if i just take here here here
here uh some end game calculation
[Music]
but i shouldn't be worse it should just
be a draw
that's so sad
i'm sure it was winning at some point
like i'm up two pawns i just had to
play like magnus carlson probably
at least i'll have a lot of pictures of
nepo to use in the thumbnail
i took i took thousands of pictures of
him
in december in dubai
world championship challenger versus
photographer
okay that was a good game
yeah i'm not sure if i played napo
before i feel like i have but
i can probably check
i'm not sure if he has a public leachats
account though
also let me change my
twitch title
oh thank you mods for changing this
okay opponents giving me time to
meditate
or giving me time to interact with
twitch chat
yeah i'll have to check my uh
my stats against nepo
some point later
okay so my opponent gave me time odds
um
i think i'll play d4
ralston played some similar move against
nebo at some point
then c5
going for reverse bononi
[Music]
yeah bishop e7
and then knight d7 i believe
the whole idea is to get an e5
and i think one
i guess bishop f4 is playable
there is some plan of uh
f65 but
there's about four i can't play f6
because rookie six i think
i only have this move
well maybe it's playable
yeah so very typical a3 was preparing b4
so i prevent it
okay e5 will come
yeah white has a slight uh space deficit
but we have a very uh kind of thematic
benoni structure
and white does have some nice piece
harmony
but okay i have a solid center
g4
like a g
i think rookie 8 makes some sense
my idea is this and maybe eventually
that
i'll start with this
if knight g3 i think g6 is called for
so unlike last game where i was down a
minute
now i'm
let's not blunder upon
i'm up a decent amount of time here
you just bishop here
reroute the bishop over defend the pawn
because i want to mobilize a knight
white's trying to hurt me
i mean it looks pretty but i don't think
i
get too damaged after after h5
and now because the pawn is here i can
happily play bishop here and not be
disturbed
uh
this doesn't pin anything
a4 looks pleasant
this is another typical manoni idea or
anti-benoni idea
um
yeah just kind of playing positionally
against the queen side
and now this pin something
getting another scan call
a decline
enough to to focus on here
i think windy seven
okay this pawn's a target
i don't have rook a5 i'm bishop g7
[Music]
he broke e7
[Music]
another idea is to put the rook here and
go for b5
which looks interesting
[Music]
but it requires moving my knight
somewhere
maybe my knight can maneuver like this
yeah things look decently
controlled oh f4 might be coming
bishop f5
i think there's about five
i do kind of can see the light squared
bishop
but this bishop's not so impressive oh
now it's more impressive
so i'm a little bit pinned
but this pond is a little bit pinned
i'm still up about a minute
things are going to explode very soon
maybe queen c7 is interesting
getting out the way of the bishop and
aligning with the king
and diagonals are important yeah now the
rook has to retreat and
um
e4 maybe i take and then play e4
takes and then e4 yeah
pawns are happy
knights happy bishop's happy
we can take this thing now
yeah i'll go for a complete paralysis
might have three is probably coming
because there's a pin
or that move
i have a knight c1
also just have this move i think is
simpler
so now there's no more pin
and now i'll play knight c1 and maneuver
to d3
and take this with check
bishop f8
yeah i can trade a little bit
defend the pawn
[Music]
uh
choices choices
maybe first check force a king to decide
now d3
and next move i'll take the pawn
okay no more fooling
around uh
check there there there
i mean there's so many ways to win this
i'm just trying to find the cleanest way
probably this move
distracting the rook from the third rank
or from the first rank
and now there's a mate threat
okay
that was a pretty clean game
a lot of uh like middle game central
tension
um i mean
we were still deep into the middle game
and all the pieces were still on the
board
like we only had one tray of pawns up
until move 24.
okay uh
[Music]
one didn't serve me well the previous
game
hey it's hannah welcome back hannah
also shout out to hannah
appreciate the resub
hope you're doing well
and thank you banff blake
yeah there's really not too much time
between games
i guess i've had a couple of long games
so far
yeah we're going into mainline london
h5 is kind of the trendy line one of the
trendy lines these days
so we'll see how much my opponent knows
here
g4
h4 is uh
one of the more aggressive lines
h5 i believe bishop g5
wg5 and bishop f6
um i this line is actually fresh in
memory
i uh
prepared this for a few opponents in
gibraltar
as one possibility to go into
um yeah so
the main line is queen b6 and bishop f6
at least according to my notes
uh there is a recent game maybe a year
ago or year and a half ago between
aronian and judah
and the game went queen b6 bishop f6
rook h7
ronian played g5 but the improvement is
knight f3 idea knight g5
so it seems like my opponent my opponent
is out of prep here
um and yes i will still be doing
gibraltar recap videos
uh
i try to explain it or explain things in
a youtube post also there is a reddit
thread i got a bit burnt out during the
tournament and then uh
then got really busy with traveling and
i'm still recovering
recovering from jet lag and a cold but
hopefully this week i'll uh
[Music]
get into a zone of recording
there's still a lot of interesting games
to review
[Music]
bishop e7
i don't know if i had studied this move
i mean this move looks enticing
just bishop b5 immediately
i'm calculating a bishop here takes and
then whatever takes back i have queen f3
hitting f7
generally f6 doesn't work because it
takes and i hit the rook so
you'll just go for this
there's castling
but castling just seems to walk into a
massive attack
in castle i'll play bishop h6
hey it's scrabble what's up scramble
shout out to scrabble if you're just
joining
this is chess
kind of like scrabble but a smaller
board
and fewer letters
also thank you fly solace solving over
20 months
i actually haven't played scrabble in a
a little while
i've been playing a lot of wordle though
maybe i'll do wordle after uh after this
tournament
because i haven't done today's daily
wordle
okay bishop h6 i think i just play
so i am allowing black to take what
looks to be a free pawn
except nothing in life is free
thank you jean paneu
it's a wonder
ah wander says i was talking about how
annoying it is to be asked my favorite
word in scramble
actually like that sounds like a
decent question
but it is annoying to be asked what my
favorite chess pieces
i've been i've gotten that question a
few times throughout my life
okay what to do here it seems close to
crushing but
it still takes work
i mean i want to take and take but
i don't want to give up the bishop too
soon i think i just take here
because if my takes i win the exchange
if pawn takes i got the g file
black is really suffering here
oh if wait yeah it might take slightly
exchange maybe there's something better
considering
uh let's keep things simple
king probably has to take
queen takes like when the
actually bishop was defended
um
yeah no need to be fancy here rook g1
maybe i will still end up being fancy
but uh up material
[Music]
d4
interesting move
let's play
what to play queen g4
not exactly what i wanted
i mean i'm not the exchange for a pawn
to be careful of bishop f3 in certain
cases
so probably oh let's not play that move
maybe this move
okay threatening rook h8
9 the 5's coming
so let's play rook h7
idea knight c4 to d6
did i just miss this move or that move
i do have this move though
i think it's okay
it takes it with check
really my pieces are coordinating well
okay so i could take the rook but if i
take the
pawn first
i'm probably just stronger
king has to move here and then oh then i
take here with check
oh no i don't because i can't move back
because my knights attack so let's play
this
i have to take with knight i guess
and then take the pawn okay let's not
flag
a4 safety first take a free bishop
simplify i had c4 okay
it does not stalemate
oh allow the queen
where's my meat
there's my mates okay
oh
not sure if that was the cleanest finish
but it was a finish
i like the opening
um
yeah i have a very extensive london file
somewhere on this line but uh
yeah bishop b7 was a bit new for me
okay playing igor
i'll stick with my london
thank you bitcoin boy
rice pudding welcome back
okay london again
this is a trendy move order to delay
knight f6
um there's cases where there's some
early queen v6 or some f6 even ideas
or bishop g4
so
uh
i'll play c3
because of knight six we would transpose
into
something
i think i'll just take and play queen a4
there's a funny line knight f6 and then
bishop a6 which is winning for white
wait
is it winning
it's winning
wait no it's not i'm getting confused
okay here i can take with night
ah because we already traded on on d6
yeah bishop a6 is only winning when
there's still tension
okay so this would be five here there's
97
if i play knight b5
looks interesting
might be five
i'm not sure how much that does though
is queen d7 queen f4 e5
queen g5 bishop g6
i have three f6
and c4
hmm
oh there's a funny line here and here
and h5
maybe i can play this right away
let's see uh
let's see what i can make up in this
position
the idea is to play jeff never mind okay
now i have this move because there's no
97
i might just be winning a pawn here
actually
thank you steven
yeah i'm willing a pawn but i'm probably
falling behind some development
okay let's see what happens
up upon
uh probably night maybe three
looks to be okay a5 have queen a4
it's weird to have the pawn in h4
because
not sure if i should be castling here
maybe i should have played a4 knight b5
rook c4 is coming
and queen a3
thinking f no f3 is bad
and i don't know what to do here
23 immediately
i have this move doesn't do much though
or does it
oh it's interesting i want to play it
i don't think it's good though but i
don't think i can resist
so on one hand i could take the pawn
another hand i was kind of like knight
here here here
takes there's a fork
it looks really awkward for white though
yeah i don't know about this
oh let's try
interesting
i still can't play f3 i'm about to flag
too
the f4
at least i'm still up upon
my only advantage here
idea 95
not so optimistic about this position
though
queen e3 idea 97
good move
to do g4
let's go crazy
oh i didn't see that idea
i have to take
oh no that's defended twice
wait i have this move though
takes takes
i have two seconds left what
i have three pawns for the piece
ah e3 is hanging
but these two things are hanging
out of hope
or a kilogram of hope
that's not what my king wanted to do but
what were the other options i should
have played king d3 i guess
though there's queen b2
[Music]
i was losing regardless what to do
[Music]
oh no my king
that went downhill really quickly
yeah i have some big memory of this g4
because the queen there's like funny
tactics but
let's see what the engine thinks
there any trap here
bishop oh bishop a6 here
i know bishop a6 is an idea in like the
other line
wow so here it's actually playable
because it kind of wins the pod
bishop a6 rook b8 takes
takes and then takes if wait if takes
takes takes
wait this is it says it's better for
black
oh knight takes c6 ah they take c6 and
queen d7
wow queen d4 getting out of the pin and
hitting g7
knight p4 will block the the file
okay what to do
lost another game
[Music]
to a gm also from russia
all these russian grand masters beating
me oh i played draev
oh i didn't know that was a tray
of oh i thought his name was igor
but it's e grok
yeah alexi drev is a
decently well-known and strong grand
master
i actually played him over the board in
philly in 2015
i drew him
actually i had like really nice opening
preparation against him in 2015.
and uh
yeah that tournament was my i got my
final i am norm there
okay i'll be right back
i have to cry a little
okay playing someone raided 1900
uh we might have a stonewall coming
c3 yeah
do i play against the stonewall
i wonder if i can like play bishop g4
and try and disturb
i've never actually looked into like the
specific move but it looks okay because
f3 bishop h5
okay 92 interesting
might as well take and play some normal
developing moves
yeah that f4 is probably coming
[Music]
i don't mind though
it feels like kind of a reverse london
got the open h file
[Music]
also kind of feels like my game with
nepo in the first round
uh but a slightly better position for me
so there's e5 here
[Music]
which maybe there's some logic too
e5 seems counterintuitive though
and rook c8
is non-committal
and bishop goes all the way back very
simple idea of building a battery
so here we see white's stonewall
formation
with a pawn here
yeah this could be a slower like
maneuvering game my plan is this and
this and this
maybe tickle the king side squares
okay my pawn can become more centralized
yeah i think we're headed towards a very
positional kind of uh
yeah more like an endgame battle
i think black is slightly better just
because i have a
a happier bishop even though the bishop
doesn't look so impressive
most of white's pawns are fixed on dark
squares
these squares are covered by my knight
if i play king e7 there is bishop b4
king f6
um
still probably worth going for
yeah so i connect my rooks
bring in the king
maybe some point i can
get the king diamond or the pawn diamond
around the king
here probably we trade
bishop here
okay it's still a question how i
try and win this
and i have some positional edge there's
b5
rook c4 is an idea
g5 ideas
now i'm moving a little bit slowly here
counting b5 bishop c5
doesn't look so great
you can just play oh there's this idea
too
[Music]
okay i think i'll play rook c4
it's been a long time there but
i think we're gonna get a position where
a lot of moves will be pretty
straightforward to play b5
bishop b6
idea a5 rook c8
thank you cool grapes and e funnel
and in de la c or laura
always a difficult name for me
i'm down a lot of time
okay the king wants to come here and
then eventually here
what to do
[Music]
i just gotta move quickly
put the bishop back
it's really hard to gain time with a one
second increment
i got my pawn diamond
i'm trying to figure out the plan though
maybe a plan is to put the recur then go
for this and this
thank you vegas subbie okay now i can
switch gears and
target the somewhat backwards pawn of
king g2 i have king e4
[Music]
diamond is very sturdy
it might get scratched a little bit but
it still
has a spirit of a diamond
okay what to do a5 now
let's play this
yeah the king is so so happy
uh-oh why wants to meet me
okay why was writing this in meat
that's the danger of being overly happy
emotions can change really quickly
okay
if i get the pawn to c2 it should be
winning because bishop a3 is now an
unstoppable threat
and seven seconds not much time but it's
enough time
[Music]
yeah i'll just simplify a little bit
okay
it's fun having so many pre-moves
okay
that's a pleasant game
yeah the uh the positional
issues for white they stemmed from the
opening
it stemmed from white having the
inferior bishop
so basically what happened this game
not to oversimplify it but
white just had
a less useful bishop and i was able to
work my way on the light squares
um
maybe there are some missed
opportunities like maybe i could play
for the right moment but
overall i think that was a feel good
game
so i'm three out of five playing
someone a bit higher aiden fellow i am
another russian
i've only lost her russians so far
let's play
let's play chess
preventing c4
yeah on passant
castling i think 97 is one of the main
ideas
because if this knight moves to d7 i
there's knight c6 to worry about
looks like a somewhat dangerous position
though it takes takes d4
[Music]
looks interesting
knight moves are c5
am i saying here the bishop is blocked
by the epon
so there's not the typical
[Music]
catalan pressure
and this move knight g6 knight d6 i can
take and play e5
yeah i really can't complain here so i
think black has slightly better pawn
structure
but it's still imbalanced it's going to
be a fight
it's going to try and maneuver to c4
trying to pressure the b-file
cutting a6 to win the pawn
which can i just win a pod here
knight a3 oh
ooh
i mean this i saw earlier i think i can
just
wait a minute
yeah this looks to be okay
because of rook c5 i have queen d6
attacking defending defending
otherwise if bishop moves i win the pawn
ah there's queen c2
or there's that move
okay it's never so simple
[Music]
so that was a train
b2 still hanging
oh do i want to take it
probably this might be four
i say b2 queen c1
rook b8
it looks reasonable
i'm thinking the bishop will develop to
b7
the rook will eventually have to move
to c5 i think
wow queen c5
i don't really want to play i mean this
is a major threat actually
what do i do
it should be seven i guess
it's not pretty though
maybe it's okay
so rook here i have queen here hitting
the bishop
idea
maybe now together work to see it
the taking doesn't work
a4 is also hanging maybe i can take and
defend
it looks shaky though
let's do it it's hard for white to
actually remove my queen
i'm up two pawns
i have this move to force a queen train
there's some eventual bishop e7 to worry
about but
i don't think it's a huge concern
it looks in the way
ah rook c1 is a consideration
i mean still
maybe i can take
oh what to do
it's really not so simple
i'm taking rook c8 i guess
bishop t4 i think i just played this
bishop d5
it's a little bit scary
at some point i probably have to lose
back upon
i'm just trying to get a playable
position with the time situation
ideally i'd like to set up with this
and eventually move the knight and
trade rooks
a lot to ask for though oh there's rook
d7
g7 we trade
oh dear i think i play this first
looks really really scary
so i'm allowing workout seven but after
king f8
or king e8
i'm still alive
there's also a line like bishop moves
she moves to c1
i don't know what's happening
i know i want to play this though
bishop a3 is kind of hurtful this move
no
oh it's very hurtful
that's a really strong move
i'm just losing
where am i i have taken this
there's a weird line
there's me stopping king a bishop e6
take on e4
also this line yeah white's winning this
i'm still gonna try and create tricks
though
really
let's try this and take
i'm getting a lot of pawns here
i think king d2 is meant maybe not
almost flagged there
no my pawns
yeah i'm praying for some miracle here
probably not happening
what to do
oh my time
yeah i was already losing
yeah bishop a3 i saw the idea i thought
i was in time to
survive
also thanks so much for the raid adam
aka
raiding with 504.
i appreciate that
shout out to adam aka
if you're just joining i just got
crushed
the bishops and rooks were too powerful
so i wanted to take
well what do i want to do
oh i wanted to play this move
but then there's takes and then takes
and then my thing gets tortured
this is actually force mage it's double
check only legal move and then mates
uh
hey i'm playing ducks paradise
uh
that sounds like a fun username
we can get some quacks in the chat
i have to quack at my opponent
with the london
oh also uh yeah there's no prediction
right now because
i think g cook left but g cook said that
if there's any other mods here
feel free to run predictions
yeah so queen d2
um
[Music]
i know this is a one of the top engine
recommendations
i think the idea is just a castle i also
have 95 though
i mean 95 makes more sense stay a bit
flexible
so i leave the bishop kind of in no
man's land
my idea of playing f3
also bishop to d3 is interesting
oh can you not run predictions on mobile
yeah
if you're a mod you might have to be on
desktop to
run predictions
okay 97
i think this position calls for more
positional chess
it takes takes
never mind
roxy won
okay some confrontation
there's a few a few things to capture
here
nothing looking too attractive though
we'll keep it uh
very peaceful
[Music]
take probably this move
so i get a little bit of initiative
giving black a choice where to put the
rook
i was thinking bishop e5 but
might be worth going for some trades
first
yeah i'll start with this
no reason to take right away hit this
move
okay that allows queen h3
i want to play 92 and get some trades
but there's 94
queen d3
there's f32 maybe
f3
it's a move i should have played really
quickly
it's so typical for these positions too
so i restrict the knight
idea 92
will trade and maybe
there's some
very small advantage
also some ideas like okay never mind
focus on the
king's side first
if we trade
a little bit too slow here i'll play
rook c2 idea
fc1
b3
so i'm down about a minute
oh that's annoying
i have this move though
it's going to be really annoying
i think it's kind of weak
i have to take
i do have bishop at six though
bishop weirdly holds things together
so 22 seconds
i have some idea of g4 like g4 g5 maybe
it's risky though to
leave my king a little bit naked
okay that i'm happy with that
we can trade king of two
[Music]
uh
okay i'll trade g3
very little time but
i don't think white should be worse here
g4 doesn't quite work
let's try this
oops
okay so my idea
yeah let's go for this and then h5
should fall
[Music]
i'm just living on the increment
the light's really out of play here
my king is on a good square too because
knight can't easily check it
oh that's a good move though
this
still playing for a win
so i have the double duo of passers
wait double duo
or just a duo
double duo would be like four
here we go
i'm gonna triangulate once
oh that was probably a bad decision
oh no my knight
okay wow what a game it's hard to play
and talk while being a little bit
congested but uh
okay got the job done
um i didn't flag i was really close to
flagging i feel like
yeah night endings are tricky
knights in general are very tricky
yeah i think black should have
should have played this move and i then
i just lose my beloved h-pawn
and i'm definitely not better
oh no not another russian
oh the russians have beat me every
single game so far
do i play stafford no i promise to play
sicilian
the one like viewer from earlier
ah this line oh i should have played
knight f6
i don't know this line
i assume this is a move
knight c6 coming e5 a move
so i prepared like a whole new
black opening repertoire in gibraltar
using sicilian with d6 on move two
which i had never played before
previously
um
this looks reasonable for black though
g6 first
some bishop h6 weirdness
might consider
like here
bishop h6
some queen a5
i just want to try it
let's try it
bishops usually don't develop to the
square usually you fiancado but
so the idea
what is the idea queen a5
the idea was to prevent the bishop from
developing to b2
if knight c3 and then bishop g7 if that
i just take and clean f6 i think
and there's knight knight before loses
okay and i have sex
thank you the shadow wizard
uh so i can't take because the thing i
was pinned
uh b4 is probably coming
so i should probably castle
and maybe my queen will dance to the
fiance square like this and this
i'm also thinking that this trade is
reasonable for me
if h3 i don't have to take it right away
i don't mind the position
okay time is looking close to level
oh what to do
i should move quicker
yeah the point like the goal is to try
and damage the white pawns somehow
there's this move
i think the queen is slightly happier
here
because i do target d2
there's cases where maybe i'm just
threatening to take
and bishop takes 95.
if knight takes him in the pawn
thank you a broken corn a broken record
a broken cord
wait a minute can i just take
yani panimayo
uh
do i just miss a d2s hanging
yeah white didn't see my arrow
and now i can take here
i also have rookie eight but
this is where i take my time and just
make sure i'm not going insane
uh this looks reasonable
there's actually a line rook takes queen
c3 hitting the rook but also threatening
rookie eight
and then there's some uh funny mate
like rookie one and then
yeah rookie eight
rookie it's just winning
it's a moment where it's okay to like
think for several seconds because
yeah opponent just resigns so the point
is that if like queen just moves away
i uh i take take and mate
very typical uh puzzle rush
idea
okay
so um
[Music]
what to say
that's a nice game hey that's my first
victory
over a
player from russia it's also my first
upset victory
this whole tournament i've been losing
to high rated players and
been losing to high rated players from
russia
and then beating low-rank players
so i broke the pattern
oh the psycho says i sent a cheer a
moment ago hello eric i'm still beginner
in chess i have decent understanding of
early game control in the center
but wondering what to do once the game
is over
wait
oh once the early game is over
once the game is over you can either
celebrate or cry
or something in between
so basically what to do in the middle
game i find mid game is where i struggle
the most and is where i lose most games
should i be looking for pieces are
hanging son of attacks
yeah
um first of all the middle game is a
very broad area of chess
and every middle game is different
uh generally you want to be working to
obviously like you should always be
looking for either tactical
opportunities hanging pieces
opponent's threat
um
i'll probably use some advice from agard
let me just make sure a game hasn't
started
we're still waiting
um
agar gives like very good advice which
applies
advice i think is intended for like very
strong players but it can apply to
anyone
is there's usually three questions you
should ask yourself and that should
guide your your middle game strategy
one question is uh
what are they what's the phone's threat
and do you need to deal with it
uh what are the weaknesses so what are
the potential like squares or pieces you
should be
looking to target
and then
last question i like
is what is your worst place piece and
how do you improve it
and if you start asking yourself those
questions then
sometimes finding the answers can be the
easier part
so maybe i'll try and apply
some of these concepts in this game
uh yeah e5
so we're following my game against akaru
never mind car played knight fd7
h3 is common preventing bishop g4
okay yeah this is some line i think 94
and takes and
[Music]
uh this pawns attack so rookie one
yeah so that was like what's the threat
the point i wanted to take i have to
defend
that question alone will can uh it can
really help minimize blunders
so i still have some worst place pieces
maybe we're not quite in the middle game
yet
i think my knight wants to be on f3
uh
c3 kind of weakens d3 so
i think knight d2 is the way to go
i'm playing manchuk
it sounds like yvonne chuck who is this
oh
manuel patron
or petrossiana
okay now i have three
some idea e6
another thing to look for in middle
games is like ways you can create
weaknesses
very often pawn breaks are a good
good type of thing to look for
try and damage the opponent's position
bishop e6 prevents that
i think i'll play bishop f4
reinforce
so i developed my final
minor piece
now i want to bring the rook into play
rook d1 is a natural move
i'm actually thinking knight g5 here
because i want to provoke some
beneficial trade
yeah the concept of trading piece is
another like very
important area or like thing to always
be considering in the middle game
like what trades are beneficial for you
which trades you should avoid
i'm just trying to provoke black to
strengthen my pawn structure a little
bit so now i restrict the knight 94
looks
playable
[Music]
and this is where i can start asking
what are the weaknesses
definitely this f6 square
so knight 6 is a some nice idea also
this pawn was just hanging
i should have looked at the whole board
but the king's side looks uh
looks enjoyable to play on
because if we if we end up trading
a knight for bishop
then i'll still have my dark story
bishop and then dark spirits will be
really weak for black
and the eventual idea is queen g7
checkmate
thank you
yips
solving for half a year
also j davis subbing for eight months
only taking a lot of time
here uh
yeah i think this is the way to go
back had to take now now it's a
it's a mission for the queen i mean
queen e3 and then bishop here and then
here's the main plan
um
but i have to be a little bit wise with
how i do this probably start with no way
e3 there's knight d5
start with bishop e5 then
queen slide down to c7 now this move
preventing queen c5 queen f8
[Music]
the calculation is queen h6 rook g and
rook d1
idea to trade rooks and then get a rook
to d8
that
looks pretty nice
another idea of d4
yeah so i'm writing rook t8 was
threatening
oh where's my mate
the thing is g5 is coming
[Music]
i want to play rook d4 but i don't think
it works
i have a funny idea this move
i think this works there's one second
left
yeah now the knight hangs
i was writing queen g7 with a nice like
queen sack for mates
okay that was pleasant
i feel like i applied a lot of the
principles i discussed like before the
game
like just trying to answer the questions
um and it was one of these like pleasant
openings
yeah i think a lot of players would play
rook d1 but
knight g5 led to more progress
and then just improve the night and then
the weaknesses were very glaring
there's a question from multiple people
well i didn't play rook d4
yeah rook d4 um
it threatens made in two
for example if knight takes then there's
a
very stylish mate
the reason i didn't play this is because
g5
is it's a typical defensive idea okay
not only here preventing rook h4 but
also enabling rook h6 or rook g6
attack the queen and i had to be really
careful
c2 is also kind of undefended
so
in the game
yeah i played h4 because it was uh
it was basically asking
the same question is what does black
want to do
[Music]
and it looks like black just wants to
take the bishop but this isn't actually
a threat
because
okay i played h4 and if it takes i have
rook d8
and this is winning there's no way to
stop queen g7
um so h5 my opponent had no time to
think still play g5 i took and
the bishop can't be taken the same idea
okay life goes on playing gm becca
oh i'm playing ingit
i played engich at the
uh collegiate
as a pan-american intercollegiate
uh whatever tournament
back in 2016 i believe
he's known for playing like weird
openings he's probably gonna do some
knight c3 stuff
um
[Music]
debating what to play here
take some bishop f5 maybe
[Music]
i usually don't play this move order but
i think it's okay here
and now
knight
c6 if queen b3 there's queen b6
there's also queen c8 here if i want to
be extra safe
there's also this move too
i'm realizing
queen b6 should be fine
because there's a line like takes takes
bishop c7 but i have knight g7 defending
the pawn
there's still some lingering tension
h4
very reasonable move
play this
i don't want to trade off the bishop
pair i also have to just move quicker
okay
make things a little bit imbalanced so
if takes i think i take with pawn
restrict the knight from coming back
f3 is a move bishop g6
oh safe travels irene
[Music]
irene uh
hope your travel's going smoothly
okay so this is a move
idea to fork
oh
i've made this whole i've made it this
whole stream without sneezing
but now i have to kind of sneeze
maybe
not oh what to do
there's a d6 and there's c4
[Music]
maybe it's playable though
the c4 i have some knight before move
i'm preventing knight f4
okay
this is playable
oh there's also this move
i'm trying to calculate
actually i think this is okay
so the calculation was takes takes and i
take and hit the rook and
thing would be tied down to the bishop
so there's no castling
did you get sick traveling
uh no i i was completely fine until i
got back
and i just have like a common cold i
think
um
i spent too much time in the cold a
couple days ago
okay let's try and focus here
93 is a good move
okay not the most pleasant structure
white has a bishop here too
try to make the most of it though
now here i have f5 ideas
bishop c7
take bring the knight back
not entirely sure what my plan is here i
should ask myself the questions maybe
improve my workplace pieces like my
rooks
another question to ask is like what's
the best square on the board for my
knight or my both my knights
i'm not sure
d5 maybe
uh knight's coming to b5
yeah opponent is doing a better job at
answering these questions
maybe g5 gain some space
g4 ideas
improve the king
i have to be careful putting the king
where it can be targeted
i think i'll just hold my ground for a
bit
this could be an idea
my rook should be on c1 though or c8
idea this and this probably not
uh
i feel like my knight should be on c6
y69 is coming to c4 and then e5
means my bishop should come back to c7
then i have to watch out for that file
maybe my knight should be here
really unpleasant to defend this
bishop c2
i want to play this move
no i saw my time i was too slow though
ah
i got the f4 square too
[Music]
i should have uh if i have time rook h8
and black should not be worse
that's so sad
we checked the final
the the evaluation of the final position
maybe white's still slightly better
actually
yeah white's slightly better but rook h8
will move to play which is too slow
what to do
good game though
when it comes to suggesting moves i
guess generally you shouldn't suggest
moves
when there's still a game being played
but these turn oh i'm playing casting
in these tournaments uh yeah i'm not
really looking at chat
you definitely shouldn't suggest like
moves in a sub
alert
i guess that's the right etiquette
okay it took me 11 seconds to play c5
let's try and
regain some time here
christinook is a former world women's
champion
we played a few times before
no one time i played her she fell into
some stafford gambit trap
but no staffer gambit today
uh c4 is interesting
yeah i might be walking into some weird
like opening prep here
i get some position with a bad bishop
i think i have to castle there's king e7
too
[Music]
i think b5 could be coming
i wonder if i can just play b6
hold off on making decision
what to do with my king
because my b5 seems a little bit over
ambitious
we'll see
the goal is to just uh
yeah complete development
i'm allowing b4 bishop b7
so i'd probably end up casting very soon
there's knight t6 yeah
oh i'm getting outplayed kind of
white's getting the bishop here not the
end of the world
i should probably take and rook d8
thankfully i can't double up
so maybe i can take over the d file
this one knight e4 idea
very positional game
and e4 doesn't seem to do anything
also thinking a5
kind of interesting
a5 bishop c3 though
but then 94
this is a positional idea
the goal is to provoke b5 and then
secure a nice outpost on c5
the problem is white might be able to
get away with this and have some bishop
d4
uh but we'll see what happens
bishop d4 i have knight d7 defending and
controlling c5 as usual down a lot of
time
so 95 i want to play knight e4
oh i miss ricty too
oh but then she had rick d1
okay maybe it wasn't a big mess i should
have considered rook t2 though
that's a very simple fork
it's still kind of looming
knight c5
yeah definitely there's like some okay
never
mind so here i probably should take
f6
it's a little bit clumsy
e5 probably
some knight d3 i'll play e5
my pawns should be on dark squares
because i have lights with bishop
my only bishop
i'm going to get my bishop here
and then redevelop my knight
only swear to
develop too
my d5 would be interesting
decision
f7
so if takes i have g6 king g7
yeah for
[Music]
probably worth taking
it seems wrong but
i do this and this
though maybe i keep my pawn on f6 and
just kind of chill
oh there's f5 though how five i take
h5
must be really careful i think f5 and
out of six
it does allow takes and takes which
gives way to passer but i think the
pawns are
vulnerable in some way
so i don't know what my knight's doing
there
okay so we got this position
[Music]
yeah i thought the um
especially the c pawn is a long-term
target
maybe i maneuver to d6 and
have two pieces always staring at c4
i don't know why plan is here
the plan should be not a flag
so watch out what she's doing too
where's my knight wanna go
my knight has mobility here
to f6
almost no time
there's some bishop here and here and
there
h5 may be coming
maybe not so g5
and g5 should be fine for me
this f3 is probably coming
so i'm like g4 chuck
that's a good move
so what is this end game
c4 is a bit weak
oh i'm in trouble
i think
where am i
oh i'm in trouble
or am i
takes takes
i'm in trouble
ah she outplayed me
any stalemate ideas
no
well played
i got ground down
[Music]
uh resign
resign
ah that was painful
i guess i allowed h5
maybe i should have played h5 myself
i didn't cross my mind
h5 allows a knight to someday maneuver
here
yeah it's still unpleasant
um i think actually by the time we reach
this position it's very close to loss
lost for black so
there's two passers and this pawn isn't
dangerous
was that the that wasn't the last round
was it oh that was the last round
oh the turn is over
okay well time to
time to go cry i guess
oh no
ah i have to identify boats not this
again aren't planes just boats of the
sky anything can be a boat if you
believe hard enough next ah there's more
boats okay boat boat